your car began its life billions of
years ago billions of miles away in deep
space
make up cars those atoms most of them
were forged well before our Earth was
born
car is a clunker
it's actually
13.8 billion years old
all right let's do it sir
it's the stuff that cars are made of
best way to find out
tear one apart
iron Plastics
oils and rubber are the first to go
another half hour or so this baby is
going to be a very stressful
I can't wait to see it
then aluminum silicon copper and finely
precious metals like platinum and gold
each of these materials is crucial for
building a car
but in the earliest days of the universe
none of them existed
13.8 billion years ago time and space
are created in the Big Bang
[Music]
the early universe is filled with
nothing but energy
after the big bang it was just a chaotic
glob of stuff nothing like what you see
today
as the early Universe cools the energy
gives way to unstable matter and
antimatter then protons and neutrons and
finally atoms but none of them are iron
silicon or carbon these vast gassy
clouds are mostly hydrogen
made from hydrogen building blocks
an atom of hydrogen is the simplest and
lightest atom in the universe just a
single positively charged proton bound
to a single electron
the universe then builds up bigger atoms
like carbon and Iron by fusing hydrogen
atoms together
everything starts from simpler Origins
an iron atom is actually lots and lots
of simple hydrogen atoms that were stuck
together
at first this versatile proton building
block doesn't want to stick
photons are positively charged so as you
push them closer together they're going
to resist coming closer together they
really don't want to hang out
this repulsion makes the early Universe
a Maelstrom of hydrogen atoms swerving
to avoid each other
[Music]
pushing atoms together so strongly they
stick is called nuclear fusion it's the
first key step for turning a universe
full of gas into one filled with the
ingredients for people cars and planets
so how do you get two atoms to fuse
this guy's been doing it in his garage
since he was 14.
Taylor Wilson is obsessed with nuclear
fusion
[Music]
okay we're getting power from the
laundry room now
Taylor passes a high voltage through a
small spherical cage that sits inside
the reactor the negatively charged cage
quickly draws the hydrogen ions inside
it
so it's taking all those ions and
sucking them towards the center as they
fly in they get confined and hopefully
they collide with each other and fuse
the temperature of the atoms Inside the
Cage is now so great that hydrogen atoms
are fusing together creating heavier
helium atoms and a burst of energy
hotter than the surface of the Sun
it's that little tiny blob of plasma
inside those grid wires that's kind of
like a star in a jar
13 billion years ago the universe uses
gravity to fuse atoms instead of an
electrical cage
across the cosmos vast clouds of
hydrogen gas collapse under their own
gravity
pressure and temperature build as more
and more gas gets sucked in
eventually Fusion Sparks deep inside the
core of these giant balls of gas and the
first Stars start to manufacture many of
the heavy elements that make up your car
today
R is basically a machine for turning
lighter elements into heavier elements
Fusion takes place only inside the core
of these first Stars fusing hydrogen
atoms together to create helium
and when all the hydrogen in the core is
used up the star finds a new fuel to
burn
after you burn hydrogen to form helium
the core of the star begins to collapse
and get hotter and there is enough
energy then to fuse three helium nuclei
into carbon
and then that fuses to form nitrogen
oxygen silicon iron
but this incredible production line of
elements can't go on forever the heavier
atoms you ram together the less energy
you get out so you turn hydrogen into
helium helium becomes carbon nitrogen
oxygen but every time there's a bit less
energy to be had
until you get to iron
the iron that is in your car is actually
essentially a deadly poison when it
comes to a star it's robbing that star
of the heat needed to keep itself up
so the star collapses dies and explodes
at the moment you create iron in the
core
I mean literally the fraction of a
second I'm not kidding that's how
dramatic and weird the steel in your car
is
explosion called a supernova
it's one of the brightest and most
violent events in the universe
it releases enough energy to dwarf what
the sun puts out over its entire
lifetime and all of the elements that it
is created are then dispersed out into
space
the gassy remains of the explosion are
called a supernova Remnant an expanding
bubble of hydrogen gas from the outer
layers of the star that mixes with
Stardust the carbon oxygen silicon and
iron from its core
and this same 13 billion year old
Stardust helped you drive to work last
week
this was once in the core of a Dying
star and who knows maybe some of the
iron atoms in this brake disc were
forged in the heart of the very first
generation of stars that illuminated the
universe
popping iron
you're pumping the universe
[Laughter]
the first generation of stars created
the materials in a car's chassis body
windshield and seeds but we're still
missing key components like the copper
for the car's Electrics
create this crucial metal a new
generation of stars must die an even
stranger death
picture our universe as the very first
stars come to the end of their lives
[Music]
the early Milky Way is filled with
flashes as star after star explodes
violent supernovas hurl a rich cocktail
of heavy elements into space
carbon silicon aluminum and iron atoms
that will one day build our cars here on
Earth no no